good morning everybody
my name is mark prescott i'm a
primatologist by training i now work at
the
uk's national center for the three hours
a scientific organization
established by the uk government to
fund alternatives to animal research and
to work with scientists to implement the
three r's and for the past
10 years i've been leading the centre's
program on improving the welfare of
primates used in research so this
presentation is going to be about
social housing of non-human primates and
how you can facilitate that and it's
really born out of 10 years of
reviewing research proposals
involving the use of primates
and encouraging and facilitating others
to
provide social housing for their
primates
it's going to be a practical and visual
presentation
i'm not going to be presenting
very
many data or citing the literature
heavily but nonetheless i think you'll
find it a very interesting and useful
presentation
this is the overview of my presentation
i'm going to talk first of all about the
benefits of social housing and then
refer to some of the legal texts which
encourage social housing and then make
some comments about things that can
facilitate social housing like a large
space a complex space
socialization of the animals and
choosing
compatible
animals in establishing social groups
and then the importance of a flexible
enclosure design
to enable
scientific procedures to be performed
and husbandry procedures to be performed
with group housed animals
and then finally i'll touch on um how we
can challenge some of the perceived
scientific requirements for
single housing and then to summarize at
the end
please feel free to
submit questions throughout the
presentation
and i'll answer those
at the end
so the benefits of social housing well i
think everybody working with primates
recognizes that
uh
these are gregarious social animals and
group housing is really fundamental for
their welfare because it enables uh
social behaviors like grooming and
social play which can benefit the
psychological well-being of the animals
it reduces behavioral abnormalities we
have quite a
a large data set
supporting that it can buffer the effect
of stressful situations such as
veterinary or research procedures
and it usually means that animals are
housed in a larger space and each animal
has use of that larger space
which can mean that they are more able
to perform natural behaviors which again
will benefit their welfare
it can also make more efficient use of
the space within a room
and it can mean that because the animals
behave more normally we have more
normative species data which can be of
greater scientific value so there are
many benefits of social housing of
non-human primates
and accordingly social housing is
recommended as the default standard
housing configuration for
primates used in research in many legal
texts and professional guidelines and
i've just put a few of them on this
slide
and
all of the texts generally
recommend that primates are housed
socially
unless there are veterinary or
scientific
or welfare reasons
why you might house them singly so
just looking at the european texts you
can read it for yourself i've put up the
new european directive and the appendix
to convention ets 123
and they say that the only exceptions to
social housing should be either for
veteran reasons or where an experimental
protocol demands it to ensure good
science
and similarly
within the usa for example the animal
welfare act encourages
um
or requires that people address the
social needs of primates
and again uh recommends that the ilr
guide recommends that animals should be
housed socially in pairs or groups
um
except
where single housing is required for
experimental reasons or because of
social incompatibility
but it's quite clear that the
interpretation of what constitutes a
scientific reason for single housing or
veterinary reason
can differ
between establishments um
right around the world
and this is evident from
the review of research proposals that i
do
um that are submitted to the major
research funding bodies like the medical
research council
or the welcome trust in the uk
were
a team of scientists is proposing
primary research which may be conducted
anywhere in the world
and within their proposals they may
suggest that they will socially house
the animals or they will singly house
the animals
over the ten years that nc three hours
has been reviewing these research
proposals and our role
is really to look at the animal welfare
implications and the opportunities for
implementing the three hours and we do
this
while the scientific review
is ongoing using international peer
reviews from around the world
we've reviewed about
450 proposals
since we
first
began
uh this review in 2004.
i'm just having a little bit of trouble
with my slides here
please bear with me
i think what i'll do is i'll carry on
with the the voice while i wait for the
computer to catch up with me
so one factor that probably contributes
to the ability to more easily socially
house animals
within the
eu i think is the
space allocations which are required
under the directive and convention
within the eu
for
macaques for example there is a minimum
enclosure size
uh the cages must be 1.8 meters high and
there must be two meter squared of floor
space
um
for
two macaques over three years old
this means that no double tears are
allowed and it means that the animals
can get up high
in a position
um
probably on eye level uh with their
human caregivers
and the fact that you can house one to
two macaques in this what is effectively
3.6 meters cubed space
means that the legislation is
encouraging per housing or group housing
of animals
now
elsewhere these space allocations are
not as generous so for example under the
ilr guide a macaque
of 3 to 10 kilograms
must
have at least
0.76 meters cage height and 0.4 meters
floor space
so that means that the minimum cage
dimensions uh
according to the ally guide are six
times smaller than those in the eu
so certainly macaques in the eu are
given
um generally more space
and this is illustrated on this slide
now the advantage of more space of
course means that you can make that
space more complex it's more easily
it's more easy to enrich that space
so the types of enclosures that it's
common to see in
european contract research organizations
or universities
are shown on this next slide
the slides are taking quite a while to
load apologies for that
so gang housing as it's often called is
very much the norm within eu research
establishments and typically um
what you see these days is cages which
are um effectively built into the room
space rather than freestanding um
commercially available uh stainless
steel caging
and this type of caging is really nice
um
it can be very easily enriched
many of the enclosure designs are very
flexible so that you can close down the
space to house smaller groups or expand
it
to house larger groups and we've found
that the animals are less aggressive in
this type of enclosure
they're calmer they're more easily
handled
there are more opportunities for them to
retreat from
animals that they're perhaps not getting
on with they can manage their social
interactions more easily
so there are lots of benefits for
welfare
this type of caging has been approved by
client companies of contract research
organizations
and
regulatory studies have been performed
in this type of housing and
none of the data have been rejected by
the regulators
so here you can see
um
a stainless steel play area on the right
which is adjoined to a bank of stainless
steel caging
in a university
again giving the animals space that can
be enriched and here's a very nice setup
at a uk cro
where you can see group housed animals
with the verandas
with
a
space that can be divided with visual
barriers so the animals can
get away from each other and the animal
at the bottom there coming up through
the pothole that is actually an upper
level to the enclosure that you can see
on the left so that's a
enclosures that run over through floors
and again this means that animals can
get away from each other and manage
their social interactions better
now
this type of housing social housing in
eu compliant cages that are well
enriched is a requirement
under the nc3rs primate guidelines
which we developed in 2006
and which are adopted by the major
funding bodies that you can see on the
bottom there
so if anybody receives funding for
primate research from any of these major
funding bodies then they must provide
social housing and eu size caging and
environmental enrichment wherever that
research is conducted in the world
and this has really led to changes in
practice in many facilities
funded through the uk funders so to just
give you an example
um
working with the facility nc3rs was able
to
encourage
and
insist in fact that
40 al monkeys which were used in a
malaria study in south america were per
housed in cages 3.6 metres cubed instead
of singly housed in cages 10 times
smaller so this is a very powerful
driver for changes in practice
but how have the facilities been able to
adapt what they
normally do in order to meet the
requirements well they've done this in a
number of ways if we look at the first
of all the cage space
in situations where people have
conventional stainless steel type caging
and what they've been able to do is to
remove the dividers between adjoining
cages
enable
in order to give
the animals a larger amount of space
so
within the us for example we would
require that six of these cage units are
joined together um and you can house two
macaques within that space and so
customizing the existing caging is one
way in which you can meet the space
requirements and that has been done in a
number of facilities
an alternative is to
build an additional enclosure we often
call them play areas these can be built
quite cheaply from wood and mesh and
that is a joint to the conventional bank
of caging and we give the animals the
run of the whole space unless you need
to confine them for a veterinary or
scientific purpose and you can enrich
that wood and mesh play area um with
swings ladders perches etc
to really give the animals the
opportunity to perform more natural
behaviors which benefits their welfare
and again this has been done on funded
research projects and can be done
relatively cheaply
i have already mentioned the importance
of a complex environment
for the animals managing their social
interactions um on the left you can see
it's actually a breeding environment for
rhesus macaques um and on the right we
have the san angus macaques and again
you can see the complex space the pop
holes uh the visual barriers which
enable the animals to get away from each
other
and manage their social interactions and
it's really felt anecdotally
that this is
much more successful
housing arrangement for social housing
so moving away from cage space and cage
complexity
it's important to think about
where the animals are sourced from how
you create your groups of animals and
how you monitor them in the long term
so that you have stable groups which
really last
a colleague of mine at the nc3rs
catherine chapman
conducted a survey recently which was
published in 2013
looking at the success of
social housing of macaques used in
toxicology studies
and you can see from that first line
there
that um
eu and non-eu sites are very successful
at socially housing uh adult female
macaques and juvenile macaques but there
is a difference
in the success of social housing of
adult males between those two regions
things that can potentially account for
this
are
whether pairs are established prior to
dosing and whether the pairs are
established utilizing information which
is provided by the supplier about the
compatibility of the animals and their
social history
in the eu sites the animals typically
originate from one group so
compatibility is already partially
established and using behavioral
analysis tools you can identify animals
from within that larger group with which
to form your groups that then go on to
study
and this is something that some cross
have a lot of experience in
and indeed some of the animals will be
supplied with an individual history file
which gives information about
the relationships between the animals um
who they've been grouped with previously
and this means that study directors can
actually use these socialization data to
assign animals to groups um
either
sometimes taking into account the weight
of the animals and sometimes basing the
groups
solely on the socialization data
um
these data uh can be gathered by
observing the animals and looking at
their behavior towards each other
this can be done at the reading center
it can also be done
within the establishment when the
animals arrive
what many people do is to look for
dominance behaviors and subordinates
behaviours performed between individual
animals and by counting these you can
establish the hierarchy within the group
and then select animals for pairs or
groups that show clear dominant
subordinate relationships and in that
way be confident that you have animals
that are likely to maintain that
hierarchy and get on with each other and
actually there's quite a literature
published in this area about pear
formation certainly for adult male and
female macaques
and these data are being used in
practice to create stable groups so you
can look at aggressive behaviors like uh
threatening grimacing yawning and
charging and subordinate behaviors like
lip smacking or rump presentation and
ensure that you are establishing
compatible groups from the start and
then the idea is to maintain those
compatible groups throughout the life
and use of the animal
and it is possible to house animals
socially even during quarantine i know
that some facilities which are set up to
handle very large batches of animals
will house them
singly
but some quarantine facilities are
moving away from that traditional
practice
one issue is the time that is required
to
establish compatible pairs or groups but
if that's done at the
source then
i i wouldn't accept
um that time as a reason why you should
singly house animals
in quarantine
there is concern that if there should be
disease
either individual clinical or
subclinical disease
then this could spread within the room
and this is sometimes proposed as a
reason for singly housing the animals
during quarantine
but to be honest i think common practice
is to treat the entire room
or at least the nearest neighbors
if you do have animals with a clinical
subclinical disease
so if you would do that anyway then it's
not really an argument for single
housing
so
we have successfully challenged the
requirement for single housing in
quarantine
we've also challenged the requirement
for single housing
in
neuroscience studies
using the cax
there is a move i think towards housing
animals with cranial implants
together
it may not be possible at all times but
it is certainly uh the standard within
uk neuroscience facilities
that animals with perennial implants are
housed together
um some of the
newer implant designs
which can be kept
more easily clean and free of infection
do certainly facilitate this but even
animals with
cranial implants
made of dental acrylic
are housed together and
people
do sometimes say oh well you know the
animals can pick at the implants um but
really this is the case whether the
animals are in single housing or group
housing
and we found over the years that there
has not been
um
additional damage to the implant and
you can successfully house neuroscience
animals in this way
similarly it's possible to house
animals on toxicology studies in groups
and this is commonly done within the uk
in the eu
and so even to limited animals
or animals on infusion studies
which will be wearing jackets
uh can be housed socially
um key to this is designing
a good jacket design that the animals
are comfortable with um
and that they
don't try and uh get out of and
very long durations of social housing
can be accommodated um of course the
telemetry devices themselves there are
companies which produce devices which
transmit on multiple frequencies so
you can have a number of telemetered
animals within the group with the device
transmitting on different frequencies or
indeed
where you don't have those devices it's
possible to house a limited animal with
a naive companion which is not too
limited and in that way provide
companionship for those animals
other procedures or other
data that are collected for animals and
toxicology studies
include food and water consumption
and clinical signs
now it is
uh difficult to measure individual food
and water consumption in growth housed
animals um but it is possible to really
question whether you need those
individual food and water consumption
data and whether instead you can observe
the eating and drinking behavior of the
animals and monitor their body weight
and that may well be sufficient to
identify treatment effects that might
reduce appetite
um
similarly
some people say it's more difficult to
record clinical signs such as vomiting
in animals that are group housed
um
that depends on
the monitoring systems that you have in
place for the animals
but
i think it has to be recognized that
actually animals in a socially housed
environment
display more natural behavior
and it may be possible to identify
disturbances to that behavior more
easily for animals that are housed in
groups rather than singly housed animals
which may be
relatively inactive and and quite
depressed within the cage so it's
um more feasible to identify changes in
locomotion uh balance coordination and
certainly interaction with conspecifics
in group housed animals so actually the
group house environment can be more
informative in terms of the effects of
drugs upon the animals
another procedure
which may be performed on toxicology
studies is of course urine collection
um
one should always question whether you
need a total collection of urine or
whether a spot sample would be
sufficient in which case you can train
animals to cooperate for that
if you do need total collection
it may be that you can continue to house
the animals socially but just separate
the individual or individuals
from which you are collecting urine
in a space within the cage and this is
where really flexible enclosure designs
are really important and so here you can
see an example
from a german cro where we have the cage
on the right and at the back of that
cage is a an area where the animal can
be confined
for short periods um for procedures in
this case urine collection and you can
see the setup on the left
which enables you to collect urine from
that animal but keep it within a social
environment
similarly these cage designs which allow
you to
confine animals temporarily
but still allow so
auditory visual olfactory and in some
cases tactile access to their con
specifics can't be used for example
to
measure individual fluid intake for
animals on
fluid control where they're working
for fluid rewards or neuroscience or
behavioral studies you may want to first
of all establish how much fluid that
animal would ordinarily take
when it has free access to fluid so you
know what the baseline fluid intake is
for that animal before you begin your
fluid control regimen and you can do
that by
temporarily dividing the animals within
the enclosure
so that they can't access each other's
water
only their own water bottles you can
measure individual fluid consumption but
still allow them social interactions
even when animals start on the fluid
control regimen it's still possible to
house them in groups
uh for example you could have an animal
on a fluid control regimen
and a naive animal and when the animal
on the fluid control goes off to work
within the laboratory then you can give
the other animal fluid free access to
fluid
it's important to monitor both of those
animals to ensure that they're
achieving sufficient fluid of course and
these areas where you can separate off
the animals but keep them housed
socially are also useful for
post-operative recovery following
surgery
where you want to allow the animal to
space to recover but you don't want to
keep it out of the social group for a
long time in case the hierarchy should
change within that group so that you
when you reintroduce the animal you have
a situation where the animals are
fighting
and the group breaks down so generally
it's thought that it's important to get
the animals back into the social group
as quickly as possible and it may be
that they can recover from surgery in a
safe place but still within that social
environment
another reason that is sometimes given
for single housing of animals is ease of
capture i don't think it's a very good
reason
um
and the comment i wanted to make here is
that
uh establishments that we've worked with
to move away from single housing to
social housing
can often agree to the social housing
without really thinking through
how they're going to cope with that
social housing and perform their studies
at the same time
so for example
if you have large groups of animals and
you need to
capture individuals to perform
sampling procedures or to dose those
animals at given time points you need to
be able to reliably access that animal
for that procedure
and that will involve
training the animals
to
cooperate with capture so that you can
reliably
take your sample and obtain your data
um
this is facilitated by again areas where
you can encourage the animals to come
forward and
sit within an area stationed
in a particular area
that you can
then
capture and restrain that animal and
perform your procedure so for example
some
cros will train animals to come forward
to put their arm through the door of the
cage it's then possible to hold that arm
to open the door of the cage to restrain
the animal as you would do normally and
perform the procedure alternatively you
can train the animals to come to a place
within the procedure like
the small boxes on the front of the
cages on the left
and access the animal in that way
moving on to other types of studies um
it is possible to group house animals
uh in infectious disease studies uh
under containment um here you can see
a state-of-the-art containment system at
a uk laboratory that has been designed
and built for
category 3
infectious agents
in this case
tb studies and the animals
are successfully housed
in groups of up to six
for these studies there is no reason
arising from the barrier system itself
while animals should not be housed in
social groups although
the nature of the experiment
the barrier is designed to contain
may or may not allow
social housing but certainly in these
studies the animals are socially housed
of course it's important that
the animals in each group receive the
same treatment such as the infectious
dose or the vaccination regime
what it is not possible to
house animals uh
that receive live vaccines uh with naive
animals because there could be immune
stimulation of the unvaccinated animals
so in that case um you wouldn't uh house
them
in groups but provided this it received
the same treatment then it is possible
to do that
i've talked a lot about macaques and of
course macaques will be macaques and um
many of you who work and manage with
them will know that
they can be aggressive towards each
other there can be instances of fighting
these are data
published data from a single uk
university
veterinary records for 90 research
macaques used in neuroscience studies
over a 10-year period
and what the data show the graph on the
right is
the number of impacts on the animals
welfare that do not arise from
procedures so it's what we might call
contingent impacts on welfare and you
can see that the majority of the animals
receive one to five of these contingent
impacts on their welfare
over their lifetime
and from the left hand graph the row at
the bottom you can see that the most
frequent
non-procedural impact on welfare is
actually
fight wounds not requiring surgery so we
know that
these
pairs or groups of macaques can
eventually break down and there can be
fighting if the animals are
re-establishing their hierarchy and it
may be
necessary to
separate those animals if they
are continually fighting and causing
damage that requires um
surgery
in that case um generally animals will
be separated
but laboratories would always try to
repair those animals with another
companion
and effectively recreate a new pair or
new group
and if that should break down they may
try a second time
and the long-term aim of course is to
get the animals back into peril group
housing
occasionally animals will be repeatedly
grouping compatible in which case they
may well be singly housed
but it's very important in those cases
to
look to ensure that you do all you can
to
ameliorate the negative effects of
single housing
and many guidelines will recommend that
where single housing is necessary um you
give the animals visual auditory and
olfactory access to companions they may
even be able to interact socially
with a limited period of tactile contact
additional enrichment should be provided
for the welfare of these animals
and if they enjoy human interaction then
positive human interaction
can really contribute to the quality of
life of these animals
that are grouping compatible and
therefore
so
singly housed
so in summary then really the features
that we feel have helped to facilitate
social housing
have been
an increase in enclosure size which
enables you to
then enrich that larger space
make it more complex
in ways that can benefit the animals
ability to perform natural behaviors
which will benefit their welfare and
certainly providing escape areas and
visual barriers and multiple perches
within the enclosure space at different
heights
and multiple for example water bottles
or enrichment devices so that there is
less competition for those resources
within the social group can really help
create a more successful
stable hierarchy
and a social group that lasts in the
long term
flexible enclosures which enable you to
divide the space and temporarily
separate the animals are very important
to facilitate the science while still
allow social housing
um thinking about
how you source and group animals and
obtaining them in pre-existing social
groups and avoiding
breaking up those relationships
can again facilitate long-term social
housing
and identifying and monitoring
compatible animals and observing their
behavior even when they're on study to
ensure that
if there are problems you can intervene
early
always challenge the perceived
scientific or welfare need for single
housing i've given you some examples of
um arguments that have been put forward
for
single housing
in the correspondence that i've had with
applicants for research proposals and
working together we've been able to
really question whether
there is a scientific need
or a welfare need and whether it is
possible to socially house the animals
and indeed in many cases it is and i
think
what has given the facilities the
confidence to move forward with social
housing where they're previously singly
housed
is really the experience of those
establishments that have overcome those
perceived problems
and it's quite powerful for
me for example to say well
all the research groups that i deal with
have
socially housed their animals with
cranial implants for many many years
and
to put the
new laboratory in touch with those
people who have done that for many years
so that they can
learn about the tips and tricks that
enable you to
move forward with social housing so my
last point really is to seek advice from
others about how they have met
the same scientific and regulatory
demands
within a social housing context
and that can give you the information
that you require to
socially house your animals and give
them those animal welfare benefits
and in some cases have the scientific
benefits
and to meet the regulatory requirements
without the need for single housing
so that's the end of my presentation
i hope that you've submitted questions
i'm now going to
take a look
and there aren't any i've probably
stunned you all into
silence it would be great if some of you
were able to
submit some questions
or even some comments you may find that
much of what i've said you do it already
perhaps
or maybe you have some requests for some
additional information about some of the
examples i've given i'd be happy to
answer them if there are any
you